Charlotte thank you so much for being
here with me today
of course so you know you're a female
Kenyan entrepreneur which is very
exciting tell me about what experience
made you want to start your own company
oh yeah so it's a very long story but
I'll make it short I grew up in mukuru
my business is called mukuro kingstos
and my daughter got banned by a
traditional stove when she was about two
years old because that is what we use
along with charcoal so I wanted to
provide a most sustainable cooking
solution for my community and so I
started a small you know side gig in
Guru and then I realized pretty quickly
that once in children was one of the
Lesser problems with inefficient stoves
and household air pollution was a bigger
you know issue to focus on so then we
set out to manufacture a stove that
would solve all the three problems so
how's the air conditioning fuel
consumption costs and bouncing children
under the age of five wow that's quite a
lofty goal how did you take that from
just an idea to being a full company and
tell me about the funding Journey that
went along with that I mean I think
because I started it as a small thing to
impact my community the pressure you
know of going big was not really there
in the beginning and so my growth was
more but I want to go into an
accelerator to see what actual
entrepreneurs do and then while you're
there you realize well this needs to be
bigger than it actually is now so it was
a really smooth journey of you know
getting local mentors were already doing
good work in their communities and
trying to emulate what they were doing
I'm trying to maybe do it better like
scale it quicker but it it's been like
obviously very challenging Journey but
because it was a passion project from
the beginning it made it a little bit
easier to do now speaking of challenges
can you tell me about the biggest one
that you did face while scaling up I
mean it is still the biggest challenge
we're facing currently
um you would think that because
household air pollution kills about a
million people every year in Africa
alone people would want to use more
efficient stoves but because of the high
rates of poverty and lack of knowledge
on the problem people still do not want
to adopt green cook stoves yeah so even
when you make a solution we use recycled
materials to make our stoves they're 10
stoves so 75 cheaper than the available
Alternatives people are still not able
to afford them because these are houses
behind 40 to 100 monthly income yeah so
they have to make a choice on food or a
more sustainable cooking solution and
how do you get people to to choose you
and choose your option
um education so we work in rural areas
so we are currently in Kenya and Ghana
and what we do is we partner with local
women groups so women and children
especially are the ones who are most
affected by household air pollution and
energy poverty so we partner with them
they sell our stoves to local
communities they earn a commission on it
they also make the stoves because we
employ them in our factories but we
partner with the women groups to educate
local communities on the importance of
switching to cleaner fuels teaching to
more sustainable fuels so it helps when
a community feels some sort of you know
ownership on a solution interesting now
obviously I don't need to tell you this
because you are a woman and you know but
it's hard to be a woman entrepreneur
especially on this continent where you
don't get a lot of the same VC funding
opportunities as men how can you tell me
about some challenges that you face
because of your gender and how you're
working to overcome these I mean the
challenges of that it's not just because
of gender so it's because also of the
fact that you're a woman yes but you're
working in the continent there's not
enough available resources and when
they're there there's a lot of women who
are doing good work I mean most
entrepreneurs in Africa actually you
know young women but we don't get
financing because there's the assumption
that someone will find your business
something as simple as then you will
have a baby and you will have to take a
break that stops them from giving you
money so yeah we've I think a lot of us
have had situations where an investor
will ask like do you plan to have a baby
anytime soon before they're able to
invest so I think it's a challenge
that's still there but I think we are
breaking some of those barriers but
having you know honest conversations
about why that is wrong and what could
happen differently So speaking of
misconceptions
um that being a big one
um what are some of the biggest
misconceptions that you think Young
Founders and entrepreneurs are up
against in Africa
um I mean just the belief that we don't
have the right Solutions I mean we come
up with Solutions every day to impact
our community and because of our
proximity to the problem
we are able to develop something that
benefits you because you know where they
should hurt so you know you're gonna fix
it a certain way to benefit the right
people so I feel like people feel like a
solution that's coming out of the West
is better but it's not always better
like we have stoves in Africa that are
way better than stores that are made in
China but just because it's made in
China and Mars people think that's the
better solution so you find that a lot
of African Founders are missing out on
opportunities just because someone
higher up decided that there is no
solution in Africa that could actually
fix that problem right which makes no
sense no it doesn't
so then what is your your big goal for
your company what's next where do you
want to take it where do you see
yourself in five ten years
um so we are working with the Astro
price at apology Island Foundation
um I mean Prince Williams at surprise
they just gave us a million dollars to
scale across
um Africa so we're doing Ghana we're
doing South Africa within the next 12
months and another thing we're doing is
we're selling carbon so that we're able
to make our stoves a little bit cheaper
So currently it's about ten dollars but
within the next 12 months we're reducing
that to five dollars so more people are
able to get access to it but we also are
in the process of developing a malaria
fighting briquette that also is going to
be sold the carbon on it is going to be
sold so people are going to access
um you know sustainable fuels and they
don't have to cut trees you know just to
you know limit or mitigate the risk of
climate change within the continent
interesting and one last question for
you what would you say is your biggest
piece of advice for young entrepreneurs
like yourself if I know you're in under
30 Africa Lister
um you obviously have gotten a bit of
recognition but how can other people get
to where you are today
I think by being with dishes
um I believe a lot of us have this thing
where we don't believe in ourselves
enough and so we let someone else fix
the problem so I would tell someone if
you know a way even if it's a really
simple way of you know providing a
solution for your community just have
the audacity to do it and then move from
there